dunder-mifflin this is Aaron he's not
available right now
uh-huh
yes sure I'll give him a message when he
gets up gets back
Michael had chicken pot pie for lunch
actually let me rephrase that Michael
had an entire chicken pot pie for lunch
and let me be more specific Michael ate
an entire family sized chicken pot pie
for lunch and then he promptly fell
asleep so we're all trying to be very
quiet so as to not wake them up before
5:00 p.m. which actually should be in
about 10 minutes what do you need from
me normally I don't condone leaving
early but I have an appointment with the
horse doctor how that horse became the
doctor I don't know no I'm kidding he's
just a regular doctor who shoots your
horse in the head when its leg is broken
like clockwork oh wow okay
all right let's all go home come on see
you all Damali my god Oh
alrighty let's get started what is she
into I know Pam pretty well I know the
things that she likes and just as
important I know the things that she
hates so one of the things that she
likes is pranks and the things that she
hates frisbee based competitions are you
kidding she I started the main frisbee
golf club at Cornell where over to
college I live to frolf lead off with
that she loves hunting she also loves
those ads for Six Flags with the old guy
then I got dad and also do you speak Pig
Latin
hello this is Dwight Schrute hello hello
this is Dwight hello hello yes we do
have that hold on one second Jim what
are you doing
and how many would you like hang that up
right absolutely I can get that out to
you immediately
this man is an impostor do not do
business with him this is not Dwight
Schrute
Dwight left his cellphone on his desk so
naturally I paired it to my headset okay
fine I'll just let it go to voicemail
hello is Dwight hey is this Dwight yes
it is oh my goodness you sound sexy oh
thank you I'm working out pam pam you
are not talking to Dwight right now
you're talking to Jim Dwight no Pam I'm
over here I'm confused
disconnect that right now you give me
your earpiece can't do that unsanitary
ah okay you know what fine I will
reprogram my phone to go to my office
phone done mr. white
oh and I forward his desk phone to mine
oh hello mutter good news I've married
tell thaw sir
such a nice woman hope this helps
are you doing Shh be scared
it works
I'm a llama ding-dong listen you're cute
there's no getting around it so I don't
know if you like country music but I was
thinking maybe one of these days we can
drive out to a field to crank up some
tunes smoke a few Macanudo x' maybe even
toss a disc around but way who date you
ain't a mph your back
Wow that was WOW Lipan night oh you know
what
sorry I forgot to tell you i intercepted
a transmission earlier and it seems the
CIA is gonna need to why you down in
their headquarters at Langley for
training and an ice cream social with
the other agents we should get him a bus
ticket to make its trip easy
I don't know that would make our $75
well maybe the CIA gets an alum powder
you have been compromised abort mission
destroy phone
Michael since it is your 15th
anniversary at the company I thought it
might be appropriate to begin the
festivities with a 15 minute round of
applause I like it
followed by a 15 minute moment of
silence I don't know is it classy enough
Jim enough with the classy okay I just
feel like after 15 years of this company
Bravo by the way that we should
celebrate with a very classy event a
night to remember I think you're right
this party has to have all the
excitement drama and intrigue of my time
here and of course classic and classy
yeah Michael you just agreeing with him
cuz he's wearing a tux don't you see
what he's doing here last week Dwight
sent out a memo about the dress code so
this is me showing him that I'm taking
it very seriously oh here's one a string
quartet playing classical music mmm you
know that's good but it's not classy I
I need something classy like the opening
of a car dealership that's it or mr.
peanut yes mr. peanut is not classic yes
he is a regular peanut he just happens
to have a cane a monocle in a top hat
that's what makes him classy okay how
about this an ice sculpture shaped like
you covered in chocolate-covered
strawberries Oh Dwight you're trying too
hard and that's just not classy you see
the thing about classy is it's a state
of mind well I'm sorry I just don't know
what classy is then okay let's just try
this one on for size and I apologize
cause it's right off the top of my head
an ice sculpture of you completely
surrounded by a variety of
chocolate-covered fruits strawberries
that's inspired I said that not classy
not classy at all day class a French
classic you ready hmm you kidding I was
born ready I don't know how to tell you
this but we have a little bit of a
problem know what the minister just told
me
and it's tradition for the bestisch
mensch to be older than the groom oh
come on I've never heard of since you
haven't heard of it obviously but I'm
out because I'm significantly other than
you not significant is a big word I
think here well okay either way he's in
a way Dwight I can't be there for you
I'm sorry Jim I just really wish there
was something I could do
Michael
[Laughter]
that's prank ever
you